Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to
[phonetically] slithair E. O.
or, at least, I assume it's pronounced "slithair E. O."
not "slither.io"
because if it's anything like agar.io and it is
in that you are a snake,
trying to gobble balls to grow longer, not that that's funny,
it's not supposed to be funny in any way,
it's a very serious game where you're literally a snake
and I think it's actually derived from the game snake,
where you're trying to get little bits in your body and then you grow longer
but in this one, there are other snakes that want to eat you dead.
And they are very good at that
because for some reason, when you grow longer,
you get a speed boost
but I don't get a speed boost when I'm tiny and short
and not really all that important.
Oh god, see, that guy, everyone's just charging off into the distance and I'm left alone.
YOU! GIVE ME YOU!
How do I get you?
Oh, that ain't good.
I only know- I've only played it a little bit,
to be honest,
I haven't gotten... good at the game
not that I'm good at Agar.io,
But,
my- my candid observation about this game is that I'm hesitant to call it "slithair E. O."
when it seems to very much be about-
OH!!!
I got him! Oh I got him good!
I don't know what I did, but I got him!
He just charged into my tail.
I kind want to call this game....
dick ball?
because it's- AH WHAT?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?!
IS THAT HOW THAT WORKS?!
I don't know how it works. How am I supposed to know how it works?
That's totally unfair.
Okay, I get it.
Okay, I got it.
Y- WOAH. Someone... died... here..
AH! Okay, well,
Okay, well, this- this is a windfall for me!
This is beneficial to-
AH
NOOOOOOOOOOO [idiot screams.]
COME ON!
HEY YOU GUYS WANNA
GO ON
PLAY A GAME OF
OF DICK BALL?
YEAH.
I LOVE DICKBALL.
IT'S MAH FAVORITE GAME.
Let's go snake up some balls and then we'll get to business.
Alright, anyway, so on a more serious note,
this game actually is much like Agar.io.
It's fun just because it's a quick, multi-player game to get into
and then you're competing with other people who are
GIANT DIL-DIL- NOOOOO GAAAAAAAAHHD!!!
I keep wanting to do that!
God damn it. I can't-
I instinctually just want to go after people
when it reality, the game is different.
I gotta make 'em- I gotta, like, circumvent 'em.
AAAH! Don't do it!
I'm not worth it!
I'm tiny. I'm small.
I'm insignificant.
Wow. This guy is big.
That guy is so big!
Why is that so weird for me to say?
AH
NO NOT ME
Oh you have to SPEND balls to go fast!
Ah!
God, that guy is circling the drain here.
Well this seems- oh God!
YAAAYY!!!
GO ME GO
AH!
NO!
AAAAAAHHHHH!!!!!
GOD DAMN IT!
I DID IT AGAIN!
God I'm so bad!
Also, I'm trying to, um,
curse less.
Not that I think cursing is bad, I mean,
fuck,
shit
and what all, but,
I was reading an article on how to be funny,
because I'm not funny
It was an article talking about comedy
and it was saying that
vulgarity is an easy substitute for comedy and wit
when in reality, it just-
it just means that you're not trying very hard to be witty
WOAH! I got 'em.
it just means you're not trying very hard to be witty
so I'm trying to curse less
and come up with actual intellegent
UHAHH
words to say a little more
and everyone knows how that's gonna turn out for me
the answer is not well
the answer is very un- un- un-goodly
AAH- WHAAAAA NO
DON'T DEW IT
I'M NOT WORTH IT
I- I DON'T WANNA
AHH! got 'em.
look at me go
I'm so good
agh I got strategies out the wazoo
outta my dick wazoo- I mean- aha- outta my- agh just leave it to wazoo
because I don't wanna put any cursing into it
OH GOD DEEZ NUTS ARE AFTER ME
why can't I play a nice game of dick-ball without deez nuts chasing me down
stupid-  dummy-
HAHA SCRUBLORD
look at how bad you are
you just slammed into the side of my long snake
ugh there's no way to say that that sounds good
and there's no way to be a- ohh
there's no way to- ohh
this seems like a trap
this seems like a hor-AHHHHHHHH IT'S A TRAP
oh I almost got him though
that would've been somethin'
EYEHHHHH
UGHHH
I just need to protect my long snake
I need to-
I just need to slither around a little better so that
my snake saves- stays safe
s- st-
ahh shut up
this is getting bizzare
EH AH AH HITLER
OH GOD HITLER AND THES'NEW
agh shit AHH GODDAMN IT
AHH I LOST EVERYTHING TO HITLER
AHH DAMN YOU HITLER
WHAT THE FUCK HIT-
aw man.
MR LERR
ahh goddamn it okay
the snake seems smoother
not so many hard edges on my-
short and shriveled snake- right now- but I mean eventually it's gonna be
big and proud an' I'm gonna have a
channel through all this place n' just not...
it's not a penis. I'm tryna be less vulgar here guys I'm tryna
substitute vulgarity with wit and it doesn't seem to be working very well
well goddamn it
is this Hitler again?
is this freakin' lerr- hit- hit of lerr
is this mr. lerr
lookit this poopy-face
look at this turd-lookin'-
uh
pants-having
funny no- god how is it
so hard to come up with insults if you're not allowed to curse
you- you stinky breath!
youuuuu smelly butt!
youuuuuu
inside-out belly button-having
weirdo
YEAH
you didn't even know how to play the game
now I know how to play the game you... SCRUBLORD
WHO'S NOT RIPPED AS ME
you're not as ripped as my long snake
pft oh god-
eughhh
so I'm just going deeper into the-
quagmire of death that lies at the heart of this map
to meet my-
meet my fate at the hands of snakes that are longer and stronger than me
but
deep I dive into the belly of the beast as I
conquer the worl- oh god
eughh this is gonna be bad
I just see trails of sprints
no you can't do that what're you even thinkin' of doin'
what're you even tryin' to do there don't even try it, G
you a- oh
well that ain't good
huh
darka
joshua
cshshoz
cshsnou shnew- nope
why did ya- way to fail there loser ass
what a stupid head. what a- AHH
*laughing*
this guy want- EBTHFFU-
it's a thick latino
why is there a thick latino
doesn't seem good at all
I'll just-
take up your sprint goo
thank you
there is some strategy to this I- I will admit, it actually is interesting strategy
because you're able to cross your own boundaries
but not other people's boundaries?
so it leads, like,
you can escape people unless lik- they fully encircle you and just like
lead you into a death and destruction spiral that's just gonna end
horribly for all parties involved
what're you doing?
I'm not even gonna tryyy
oh where am I gonna go from here
eughh god
eughh gersh
oh golly gersh
oh this ain't good
oh this ain't good I'm trapped in the belly of the beast
everyone else-
I imagine that everyone else when they're at their desks playing this game
are just screaming at the top of their lungs nonstop just like me
I mean in reality they're probably very calm like,
"ah no I didn't- I didn't make it aw shit"
but I'm just like-
*screams*
EVERYTHING IS HORRIBLE
I'M GONNA DIE DON'T TOUCH MY SNAKE
and-
that often leads to panicked moments and then horrible regrets, but everything is fine.
what's goin' on here?
WHOA- OH MY GOD THAT GUY DIED WHAT THE FRICK
oh shit
ah shit
he was big and he died
eughh
I don't know if that was worth wastin' all the sprint juice to get over there
it's not exactly my territory that guy-
benefited from it more than I did
and he shouldn't have
I'm going in for the kill
ehh
I'm not going in for any kill I'M NOT GONNA KILL- OH
ohhh
oh- AHH
oh god
DGHEEEHHHH
AHH
WHOA GAH
SUCK ON THAT
OAHH SUCK ON THAT
OHH SUCK ON THAT
ohh suck on that suck on that suck on that
AHH don't die
don't die from the little guy
just that tiny guy gets me
just the tiny itty-bitty one
tiny itty-bitty one
oh I'm doing so gooOOD
oh I'm feeling good feelings in my brain
oh- oh shit
ah weekle don't look at me like that
weegie
weegie weegle
eugh
c'mere you
nom
I don't know what that did but it was good for me I'm 28th
I'm ranked 28th
I'm  not on the leaderboards
but I'm doing meter- me-
mediocritiddliddly
meh- mediocritusly
medi- medocritusly
meh- mim floke- I don't know
remember when I said I was gonna replace my vulgarity with wit?
it just-
I- I emptied the vulgarity and then I emptied the wit
cause I never had any to begin with
so I'm just stuck with my stupid brain in my head
haha
hahaha
haha- whoa that guy's so long
oh he's encircling me!
NOOO
NOOOOO
I DIDN'T THINK SO
YOU AIN'T GONNA TRAP ME
it ain't gonna happen
cause I'm to smart for y- he's still comin' after me
why is he comin' after me?
as if I'm worth it
MAYBE IT'S MAYBELLINE
DJEHHHH
okay
ahh!
don't do it
why am I worth it?
why d'you fight me?
why you fighten' me bro
[girly squeal]AHH EVERYTHING'S HORRIBLE
ehh- okay, everything's fine
everything's fine
everything's not horrible, but it's fine
I somehow dropped rank again 'cause I spent so much-
I shat out so many balls out the end of my ass
just fuck the lack of vulgarity!
I shat so many balls out the end of my- whoa hello
so many balls out the end of my ass that
obviously I couldn't
reciprocate anything- ohh hello
hi friend
how you doinnng
I'm number 18 now
di- do I do good
that guy almost- whoo... whoaff
just scoop up the remnants of everyone else's mistakes
that's my motto in life
follow other people until they fail,
and then capitalize on all the mistakes that they've ever regretted in their life
and then make fun of them when they're dead
*laughing* that's what Markiplier- that's the Markiplier way!
oh boy
thank you
thank you helpy-helperton
this is awfully helpful mister helperton- whoaa
wehh
oh- oh- oh- so much good juices
oh so juicy
oh so juicy goodness
oh so juicy... people are just rammin' into my body
I can- I can't help the fact that they're too stupid to avoid everything that's in front of them
I'm-
whoa
whuh
seems dangerous
I'm no- I'm on the leaderboard!
'm on the leaderboard
I'm on the leady-board baby I'm number 7!
oh it's my first time playing! well like my second time playing but I didn't do-
I didn't do any sort of good the first time I played so this is the first time on camera,
and I can officially say
it's good enough!
fer ME
alrighhht
aw man if anyone takes this away from me, if anyone tries to rob me of my success
I mean it- ah goddamn it number 10
if anyone tries to take away my success from me
awe goddamn it I'm off the leaderboard
well
I can't say it was any one person it was probably a concerted effort from a whole bunch of people but-
I can't exactly complain- whoa hello
don't run into me
I wanna be a- I'm on a peacekeeping mission
I'm an ambassador of fun times and happiness
don't- hey it's another markimoo
wha'dya know?
well look at that
I haven't been able to capitalize on anyone else's mistakes just yet,
buuuuUUIT, it might happen soon or else I'm gonna make a horrible mistake
oh no
it's your mom
don't even think about it you losers
oh
hello
thank you please
oh yes kindly
yes kindly would you kin-
OHH yes kindly
oooh yes
ooh yes slay
ooh slay Markimoo I'm number 5
SLAY
YEHH SLAY
ehh slay
slay a little less
dangerously
oof ah that's dangerous slay
I'M NUMBER 4
OH GOD
I WANNA HOLD ON TO MY CROWN
AHH I WANNA HOLD DESPERATELY ONTO MY CROWN
it's a new game so people aren't exactly like-
the best at it? which is the only explanation that I can produce for me actually doing any sort of good in this game
but it's okay
*demonic wheeze* it's okay!
*wheeze* I'm gonna be fine!
*wheeze* I'm doin' good!
*wheeze* where am I?
*wheeze* what am I doing with my life?
*wheeze* can't breathe
*wheeze* uh-oh
what're you doing?
what're you doin' with that?
NOO
eugh
jeez
I almost got-
BLEGHDDFHH
NOO OH GOD NO
OH FUCK ME
AH GOD NO
AHH MY KINGDOM HAS CRUMBLED
AHH I LOST TO SOMEONE WHO DIDN'T MEAN ANYTHING
AGHH ehh shit
nya k
aight so that's slithair E O- slither-
that's- that's a good old fashioned game of dick-ball
'n if anyone doesn't like that well goddamn it you're not an American
I don't know
so anyway you can play slither.io it's totally free
link's in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you think of this game in the comments below
AND AS ALWAYS
I will see you...
in the next video.
BUH-BYE!
*Crazy la paint plays by MiniMusicMan*
Here's the end of the video. I hope you at least noticed his SWUG haircut.
...
DO YOUR DANCE PARTY DANCE!
Well, good-bye everybody! Have a great day and  Remember: Please subscribe and comment!
*Mark giggles with Bob*